bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à tam tam
canada sur les ondes
oui web de radio-canada international
bonjour ces vraiment des marteaux avec
vous stéphane parent est en vacances
cette semaine et aujourd'hui on se
penche sur la coupe du monde de foot
la coupe du monde 2010 8,7 en russie 21e
édition des les meilleures sélections
des équipes nationales
c'est du 14 juin au 15 juillet donc 14
juin si vous prenez lance presque rendu
premiers matchs à l'horaire arabie
saoudite contre russie la grande finale
c'est le 15 juillet 18h heure de moscou
changerait argentine pour casser on y
viendra
on y viendra site 11h heure avancée de
l'est ici au canada il ya 32 équipes
participantes ne cherchez pas le canada
nous sommes au 80e rang mondial derrière
le bélarus et devant les émirats arabes
unis le faute
aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur la
perception de ce sport et son évolution
cours des vingt et trente dernières
années mon équipe en studio celui qui
commente mais ô combien argentin
unilatéralement c'est bien sûr
leonardo crime unodc y est la montre aux
jo celle qui se déclare elle-même un
culte dans le dossier mais quand même on
a un collègue journaliste qui lui étant
un grand fan de newcastle dans l'est
16 salut et puis on a via skype un joie
un joueur de 16 qui se nomme michel amat
qui dit lui même je suis moins bon que
mes frères mais quand même compte joint
chez lui bonjour michel bonjour bonjour
sert bien changer les façons de de
suivre la coupe du monde on se rappelle
des années 60 70 la coupe de 70
d'ailleurs qui est au mexique
ça avait été pour la voir fallait aller
ici à montréal à l'aréna maurice richard
pour le voir en direct
celle de 66 kg et en angleterre ça a été
diffusé au canada plusieurs semaines
plus tard en différé par radio-canada
libye si ça a bien changé le faute
on va y aller avec quelqu'un qui est
peut-être grandi là dedans au même titre
qu avec son barbecue léo ça a commencé
comme en football dans votre vie mais
nous on a on a une histoire de soccer et
de football en argentine
dans ma famille et mon père c'était
fanatiques des san lorenzo del malheur
c'est une équipe bleue et rouge comme
les bars et l'homme puis a donné des
grains joueur dans l'histoire de soccer
de l'argentine mais particulièrement
dans ma famille et j'avais une tante qui
jouer au basketball dans san lorenzo
j'avais mon grand pas s'est elle par son
qui est entraîné les champs de jeu de
l'estadio sandrine sont alors je
comprends arrêté au même titre qu'un
terrain de golf en angleterre à peu près
là c'est comme cp ce1 l'histoire puis
moi je mange pas je me rappelle quand
j'étais petit noir je voulais être des
rivières et boccace et les deux plus
bien
et l'équipe de l'argentine puis on m'a
dit c'était d'arriver au débaut cas tu
manges pas alors y avait 190 ch puis
maintenant on la gelée mais bleu et
rouge les deux donc votre votre famille
traiter avec la la royauté du catalyst
absolument olivier vous le foot
jusqu'où timide en origine moi c'est ça
cesse et c'est venu sur le tard parce
que je n'ai pas grandi dans une famille
j'ai même pas de frère ni de ça pour me
traîner dans quoi que ce soit annoncé
c'est pas mon père et puis ma mère que
j'ai fait un petit peu mais que ma
culture du sport et puis forcément ça
commençait avec en suivant les cousins
qui ouvre aux qui jouent au baseball pee
ouaki tous mais sur le tard vers la mi
ou fin de l'adolescence ccc
particulièrement tous les enjeux qui
vont autour du jeu kiki qui m'ont
interpellé en premier degré quel point
ce jeu là était le miroir de toutes les
sociétés à travers le monde
sas a possédé plus je me suis perdu dans
le vortex de wikipédia non plus fini un
peu à cliquer sur têt la fable découvrir
différentes choses en faisant bien
attention sources évidemment avec
wikipedia mais
et puis ramenée de ça je suis partie des
scouts et puis ça fait ça fait longtemps
maintenant mais le terrain où jouent au
baseball quand j'étais petit il put nb
ce vol six années au parc jean béliveau
pourquoi y avait des terrains de
baseball au parc jean béliveau j'ai
jamais vraiment compris mais maintenant
c'est des terres et de la dernière fois
que ça arrive ils disent on veut savoir
où les gens ne savent pas c'est une de
nos plus grandes vedettes rock et sur go
voilà michel toi comment c'est arrivé le
faute dans sa vie moi c'est mes frères
ont commencé avant moi maintenant de me
ferait plus vieux os à bompas un coach
aussi donc on m'a mené tranquillement la
joue ce que valent ces sept ans à
longueuil
puis j'ai continué j'ai aimé ce donc
j'ai continué jj jouer ça fait des jeux
le suisse a fait comme presque dix ans
que je joue oui et puis tu as fait tu as
participé notamment un tournoi change en
europe en europe oui j'ai joué à
barcelone tournoi ya deux ans mon coach
et mon frère on est allés ensemble à
barcelone on y était on me dit qu'on est
prêt on n'a pas été à la hauteur 10 des
bonnes équipes qui a d'abord on est on
est une petite équipe de longues et donc
ça faisait deux ans quand même fini mais
cela dit c'est comme ça qu'on apprend
oui c'est comme ça qu'on apprend
beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup
d'expérience condé équipe beaucoup plus
forte que nous mais on a gagné beaucoup
d'expérience
olivier olivier tremblay vous disiez
tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui
m'intéresse d'abord et avant tout c'est
tout le processus le microcosme sociétal
de la planète dans ce sport
reste que ce sport si j'ose dire
l'amérique du nord
entendons-nous canada etats unis ils
sont un peu comme le village gaulois par
rapport brosse pas web et le canada les
états-unis ont tellement une culture une
culture sportive différente le
le modèle le modèle d'affaires est
absolument différent de tout ce qu'on
voit à travers les fédérations soit pour
la notion de la fédération au même titre
que peut l'être le foot le rugby ou même
la formule 1 c'est surtout que wayne en
amérique du nord les ligues sont reines
et maîtresse de l'arjel fédérale alors
qu'ils canada ligue nationale noc et je
pense qu'on peut s'entendre pour dire
que le rapport de force n'est juste pas
y est très très loin du côté de la ligue
nationale de hockey par exemple
donc oui on peut on peut dire que c'est
effectivement un peu un village gaulois
mais qui tranquillement aussi chercheur
s'adresse en rapprochant en garde dans
tout de même son identité la mls par
exemple n'ont pas de système de
promotion unis de rélégation
comme il ya en europe la plupart des
ligues dans le monde par exemple le
canada les etats-unis cherchent encore à
faire les choses à leur manière mais en
souffrent peut-être un petit peu
davantage sur le monde du joaillier par
exemple hier sur twitter une liste d'un
américain et d'un animateur de fox pour
le tour de tony qui faisait sa liste des
dix athlètes les plus connues dans le
monde et tom brady et en premier lieu le
quart arrière des packers de green bay
était dans la liste
messi ronaldo semblait avoir été déposée
la numéro 5 et 6 juste pour deux ans
vous ai je pensé à vos autres le cercle
mais surtout était au lieu de se faire
dire par 8 go montre leur que nos états
unis on sait comment ça marche le spa il
se faisait rabroué allègrement l'agly
nord-américains sont d'asson sont de
plus en plus son emprise de plus en plus
conscients de la portée comme ça que à
travers le monde
pis d'à quel point ça peut aussi venir
enrichir leur côté les eaux comme
matériau canada c'était ya à peu près
15h16 un way avec toute la perception
argentine de la passion du foot ce qu'il
ya eu comme un genre de déception non
non en fait les ça c'est que quand je
suis arrivé si on voyait dans les rues
en était bien sûr l'université dans les
pattes parce qu'il ya les gens qui
jouent les gens qui jouent au hockey
hockey et puis les seins ils ont passé
puis tu vois de plus en plus des jeunes
qui jouent au soccer dans les rues on
voit pas disparaître les occupent
mais on voit de plus en plus des gens
des jeunes qui jouent mais l'histoire
s'est beaucoup mon chat qu'elle est
acquis que n'importe quel
et ce par american iii michel à jouer
parce que trois triplés à hawaii et ont
perdu deux hypothèques et moi c'est ça
la maison pour pouvoir le faire
adiko maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
facile de voir si c'est comme lui moi je
voyais d'un prêt de la maison de mon
frère où j'ai invité le premier temps on
voyait des champs de baseball hybride ne
démarre plus en plus d'aider des
terrains de soccer c'est extraordinaire
puis tu vois les ligues qu'un seul sage
pas 7 8 ans il n'y avait pas trop déjà
maintenant c'est incroyable la quantité
des enfants qui font les soca comme très
bien le sport est juste pour rebondir là
dessus parce que oui on voit le sacre
prendre de plus en plus de place mais je
trouve ça intéressant de voir que ça
prend pas nécessairement la place de ce
que ça prend sa propre plage où il est
si important aussi a beaucoup donné une
des choses qui m'horripile je suis
désolé amateur de soi que
particulièrement ceux qui sont sur
twitter il ya des gens là qui veulent
que le sort que prennent la place du
hockey et que ça et que ça devienne que
ça devienne uniquement que de nom la
pluralité dans l'espace est super
important qu'est ce que leonardo a dit
tantôt à propos de sa soirée jouer au
basketball un club multisports san
lorenzo
c'est c'est bien d'avoir cette richesse
là les grands entraîneurs de ne circule
comme guardiola puis mourinho qui ces
gars là ne s'inspire pas seulement que
des autres équipes de ce que le puits de
ce qu'on a vu par le passé ils
empruntent des stratégies au football
américain au basketball il ya quelque
chose de sain dans le fait de poids et
mais plus qu'un soir oui c'est possible
de me +15 par michel est ce que ya été
possible ce qui était question un moment
donné dans ta vie que tu joues au hockey
et non pas au foot pas pour moi oh moi
mais comme expérience pour moi j'aime
beaucoup regarder quinzaine moyens mal
cette année ça j'aurai pour être
particulièrement agréable mais je
regarde autant de cases et de montréal
que de l'impact de montréal
mais ce que j'ai moins de talents qui
jouent moins bon ok ce que joue des fois
au parc dehors sa patinoire extérieure
pour le fun on y va mais c'est se joue
ce que j'aime mais j'aime ce mélo qui
c'est un autre sport que j'aime aussi
pickeu qu'il faut pas que ça disparaisse
comme sport parce que c'est aussi un
sport de savines notre culture biblique
il faut le protéger faut le garder aussi
une anecdote quand j'étais plus jeune no
97 ans je jouais au football mais au
football canadien il a le ballon ovale
avec l'immense terrain non pas le timbre
passe aux etats-unis et il y 12 voix
contre 12 et non pas aux comptes
notre football et je je m'en sortais
bien je m'amusais bien elle va c'est
quand j'arrivais au niveau supérieur
oublie ça j'ai pas la taille et la forme
et le gabarit pour le faire reste que
l'anecdote et et que mon père m'avait
présenté un de ses amis qui étaient
prêts et ricky et qui travaillait en
argentine
et quand ce su que joe football il dit
comme ça à quel point le sport est
important là le football est important
en argentine
et moi je voyais très mal comment on
pouvait jouer au ballon ovale en argent
alors qu'on parlait de foot
pour nous c'est les fautes c'est parce
qu'à ça ça n'existe pas maintenant je
sais bien sûr c'est un autre italien
parce que à cause des autres là c'est ça
est-ce qu'on sent une différence dans le
jeu quand michel quand toi tu as
commencé à jouer avec maintenant est-ce
que tu saint-jean de est-ce que tu vois
un changement au niveau des joueurs dans
le genre des gens qui viennent d'un peu
partout sa planète et qui jouent au foot
eu lieu au terrain mais depuis que j'ai
commencé à jouer même depuis que j'ai 7
ans
le sac us et l'acier leblanc québécois
c'est quasiment une minorité on peut
dire ça comme ça y est on a des arabes
des noirs des asiatiques
si c'est vraiment diversifie ce depuis
sept ans comme ça que même dans mon
équipe en ce moment
peut-être le corse et des québécois de
souche
tandis que le reste c'est des immigrés
si jj un marocain et des africains
j'ai toutes sortes de les gens qui
viennent de partout en france la façon
de jouer
je pense pas
ce qui change la façon de jouer c'est lé
coach ni coach aussi mon coach et
français encore à savoir ceux dans le
club
mon directeur technique et français ont
été les chercher en france y amener
beaucoup de coaches français avec lui
donc la façon de jouer au club
elle a changé beaucoup depuis que on a
des coaches qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc ils nous ont appris beaucoup ils
nous ont appris beaucoup la façon jouer
à l'européenne comme moi je dirais qu'à
longueuil on est un des seuls clubs au
québec qui joue plus européen parce que
la cause de sa cause de ce qu'on a
appris qu'ils le façon de jouer a changé
à cause d'eux des coachs mais de réagir
là-dessus le jeu européen et versus le
jeu nord américain est il à ce point
différent pour l'instant il est encore
quand même particulièrement séance on
regarde le niveau professionnel l'est
mais laisse les usld c'est lé glas
demain encore des délits gouès qui sait
si beaucoup d'athlètes des joueurs qui
conquit onu contrat qui ont trois
poumons parfois puis lui cinq courts
puis ça ça ça balance des ballons à la
main mais tranquillement le jeu
nord-américain de jeu européen se
rejoignent un peu plus
puis c'est pas un phénomène qui unique
en amérique du nord que le jeu change à
cause des influences qui
yann d'ailleurs quand on regarde
l'équipe allemande à l'heure actuelle
jouer on voit que l'immigration que eu
en allemagne avec des saâdane aider ça
donne des joueurs comme des comme des
utile par exemple qui qui joue à arsenal
à l'heure actuelle c'est la saison est
terminée mais bref
et on ya une influence différents dans
des familles turques qui ont émigré en
allemagne puis il ya évidemment c'est
aussi tout un travail en amont pour elle
peut changer les habitudes de jeu mais
c'est un prof est bien le moteur est ici
on voit justement comme comme je le
disais l'influencent les immigrants de
l'ailé français qui hier et puis qui
apportent leurs idées
mais même chez les pros on voit aussi de
plus en plus des joueurs qui ont fait
carrière oui aux états unis qui après ça
ils sont allés travailler en france en
scandinavie tous reviennent ici dans la
quarantaine la cinquantaine un gars
comme elle comme veux rentrer à columbus
comme greg dernier à toronto qui se sont
qui sont allés prendre des idées
c'est le 15e des joueurs qui viennent
appliquer ça ici en amérique du nord
tout en gardant leur on empêchera pas le
nord américains détenant américaine ou à
toujours vouloir repousser les limites
de son corps mais on voit différentes
influences venir se maria tous le jeu
nord américain
à mon avis est appelé à devenir un peu
le reflet d'un certain multiculturalisme
certaines l'intéressant les eaux qu'est
ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
l'influencé comme comme dit c'est michel
céline fluence des deux entraîneurs mais
je connais des gens qui est qui qui
travaillent ici avec les mii des équipes
de jeunes qui vont ailleurs s'être
préparé je connais un passant qui est
allé en argent tient faire avec l'afa
l'association de football à katyn faire
sont disons sa préparation comme coach
puis après la faille venus à toronto je
serai pas ça fait trop en trois ou
quatre ans pour faire passer les examens
des gens qui voulaient se préparer avec
eux alors tu vois c'est beaucoup plus
globale à main et discuter d
en plein dans les années 70 soyez la
différence dans l'intérêt quand c'était
un équipe sud-américaine qui fabriquait
c'était beaucoup plus les corps
l'élection c'est ça les stratégies
tallien ne s'est penché ce n'était pas
quelqu'un qui passe en tête et côté il
ya beaucoup des choses qui est souffle
mais ça a changé maintenant c'est
beaucoup plus globale pour le dire une
chose par l'excellent la sélection de
l'argentine il ya 90 % des gens et joue
à l'extérieur jouent en europe
c'est à dire que la façon de jouer bien
que la personne qui maintenant coach le
directeur technique
il ya aussi était il ya aussi travailler
en espagne la façon c'est pas
sud-américain soit c'est plus
internationaux pour lui c'est plus
globale
tu vois et il n'y a pas de différence à
dans un terrain et sinon oui tu vois les
individualités mais la différence en
tant que stratégie dans les coupes dans
les champs ça change pas beaucoup d'un
pays à l'autre
michel est ce qu'on vous montre aussi
jouer la comédie
non oui dans le sens où si aussi une
stratégie la comédie dans le sens où
c'est dans la boîte quelqu'un qui ne
bouscule un peu normalement soit pas
tombé mais tu veux te laisser tomber
comme un faux pour tromper l'arbitré ou
pour influencer les arbitres dans sa
décision
mais ces deux stratégies mais c'est sûr
c'est pas mon but c'est ça c'est une
race est pas illégal
c'est peut-être pas illégal mais dans
l'oeil noir américain et cotaient quand
c'est l'oeil de la femme qui voit pas le
soccer parce que j'en connais beaucoup
des femmes qui vont arriver dans le
local mais les femmes qui vont qui
regarde pas souvent ils disent comment
ils étaient presque en soins intensifs
ça fait deux minutes moi ce dont je
parle ce dont je parle c'est de mon oeil
nord américain c est fan de hockey ou le
contact est autrement plus dur
d'emblée évident avant de dire ok j'ai
mal faut que j'aille denjean est-ce que
la comédie à sa pertinence
michel parle de stratégie mais par
rapport à la pénétration du sport en
amérique du nord
prenons un exemple mais très récent
lundi au stade saputo zlatan ibrahimovic
qui savaient qui prend 1 qui prend un
carton rouge c'était les fans de rock et
de football américain canadien s'en sont
donné à coeur joie d'un bon c'est ça que
moody's a accueilli fake mais quand on
s'assoit pour regarder qu'est ce que
cela donne à fait particulière et est-ce
qu'ils soignent leur fais moi je peux
pas m'empêcher de riz garder ça et
d'admirer ça parce que zlatan
l'attendent au fait là comme il n'y a
pas fait la comédie parce que simplement
il voulait et il voulait du dernier
congrès du tango c'était une stratégie
pour essayer d'éviter le carton rouge je
voulais faire comme si petrasso qui
vient marcher sur le pied ne lui ne lui
avaient pas simplement marcher sur le
bout du petit orteil mais bien
que c'était que c'est un vrai
piétinement et la performance du
soigneur ensuite qui vient voir
n'attendent qu'il l'aide à se relever
certaines qui est vous qui voit carton
rouge arriver mais qui vend pas vraiment
tout à fait qu est ce qui vient
d'arriver et qui continuent d'avoir main
et soigner kills ou c'était digne d'un
détail mais me c'était faux c'était
formidable
je me souviens d'une coupe du monde où
cristiano ronaldo s'est tourné de
douleur et où il y avait même jamais eu
aucun contact
on y voit même maintenant avec les vals
assez la nouvelle technologie parce que
les reprises vidéo
ce n'était pas acceptée puis on croyait
fortement au jugement des arbitres mais
maintenant comme les faits qui voit de
plus en plus et puis des arpents comme
par exemple dans la coupe du monde pas
2014 française 2010 la france y est
rentré avec une butte de qui étaient là
mais n'en faites dans l'âme et la
matière a déterré en reste et incroyable
puis à passant qui a dit rien en fait
dans la télé on voyait que c'était
vraiment elle a tendu le bras qui n'ont
jamais rien fait
mais si elle est là elle est là la
reprise vidéo
la france n'avait pas participé de la
coupe du monde quelques petites notes en
terminant marie claude auger une
question parce qu'au mois de juillet je
vais être au royaume-uni open ce que je
peux m'attendre ce qui est de l'ambiance
dans les pubs
oui ça dépend si l'allemagne perd ainsi
la dengue bas encore l'angleterre sur
penalties a peut-être un peu plus un peu
plus abattu mais oui forcément
c'est moi je le laisse son image de
buenos aires il ya son matelas spéciaux
juste pour vous dire on est 80e au monde
la meilleure sélection du canada on
était 40e
c'est en 80 sexe le pire classement 2016
117e mais au niveau mondial le canada a
été éliminé au premier coup en coupe du
monde 2 86 vainqueur en 85 et 2000
concacaf et gaulle coop et médaille d'or
ou faute aux jeux olympiques de saint
louis
c'est en 1904 mais c'est un sport de
démonstration heureusement que l'équipe
féminine
heureusement qu'eric et féminine pour
sauver l'année coupe du monde qui
commence là sous peu en russie vos
prédictions
on y va avec vous mais aude
quand j'ai quand j'ai vu la liste de
l'espagne sortir il ya quelques il ya
quelques jours j'ai été vraiment j'étais
vraiment intrigué je pense que l'espagne
a une très très belle équipe on connaît
l'identité de jeu de l'espagne réponse
et quand on regarde tous les joueurs
qu'ils ont exclu on pourrait faire une
équipe formidable avec 11 joie qui sont
même pas dans les 23
donc le 15 juillet 11h heure avancée de
l'est ici
l'espagne jouera contre qui contre
l'allemagne probablement contre
eux-mêmes récente quoi allemagne-brésil
l'espace les trois candidats c'est que
je veux ce que l'argentine soit 9 mai
c'est si difficile argentine portugal ça
serait bon michel mon idéal ce serait un
huitième finale argentier
il gagne contre le portugal mais moi je
suis ronaldo un quatrième finale contre
l'allemand un des mes final un gain
contre l'espagne puis
la finale contre le bacille c'est ça que
je veux michel toi moi de coeur j'espère
que la france boga coupe du monde mais
je suis d'accord de dire que l'espagne
je pense sur papier à la meilleure
équipe pour réussir et ont beaucoup de
nouveaux jeunes beaucoup de nouveaux
jeunes comme ascencio beaucoup de
nouveaux talents que même même si la
france en a aussi beaucoup ont quelques
blessés ça veut jouer là dessus mais de
coeur j'espère que la france bon
sélectionneur danois sera pas d'accord
il a dit des choses terribles sur
l'équipe de france a les googlers ça et
moi je me rappelle la finale brésil
allemagne et j'ai l'impression que
quelque part chez les brésiliens on veut
une revanche la latitude il est certain
le 7 un os et sa noblesse et n'oubliez
pas pour moi c'est une souris un ordre
on se rappellera toujours dit qu'on
était quand on a vu ce match pour un
examen après midi non merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à l'émission
aujourd'hui c'est très gentil et ouais
mais ça vous saluer merci beaucoup
olivier tremblay grand plaisir ça y est
hier soir qui est partie de chez minuit
mkii rentrer quand même pour le faire
l'émission c'est très très gentil mais
ne commandite d'une marque de café
et puis notre équipe ici marie claude
simard est libre d'aller on a beaucoup
aimé no merci beaucoup monsieur ali si
le monde et marteau salut à une
prochaine tout le monde
au revoir merci